the left ardently desires to paint all
Republicans is racist none more so than
Trump attorney general appointment
Senator Jeff Sessions sessions has been
hit with allegations of racism over and
over he's got actual racist al Sharpton
protesting him senator cory booker
Democratic New Jersey is scheduled to
testify against sessions presumably on
the basis of race and also because
Booker is preparing to run for president
in 2020 but the left's desire for the
races in charge doesn't stop with
sessions it affects even his
grandchildren here is MTV News culture
writer IRA Madison the third not the
second of the first he wrote sessions so
kindly returned this Asian baby to the
Toys R Us you stole her from and it's a
picture of Jeff Sessions with a small
asian child on his lap and they says the
girl on sessions lap is not adopted it's
his granddaughter which is not
surprising there's no reason for that
child to be in his lap and hearing other
than to send and I'm not racist message
why is she a prop sessions argued for
policy that in the 1880s was used to
discriminate against asian-americans in
fact Americans have long used asian
americans as model minority since the
rise of the civil rights act etc etc etc
so basically what he is suggesting is
that this asian child is just a prop he
so you know what's what's the point of
all of this the point of all of this is
that sessions grams authorization that
doesn't mean that he doesn't secretly
hate Asians and everyone else wasn't
white which is disgusting sessions has
always been tough on illegal immigration
and in favor of heavy restrictions on
legal immigration that's not race
specific or race centric as for the
aesthetic of a granddaughter sitting on
sessions lap during the hearing is that
supposed to be off-putting or
politically gauche I mean Nancy Pelosi
did it we saw Bill and Hillary Clinton
do it this isn't the first time leftists
have attacked a Republican for the sin
of cross-racial grandchildren in
December 2013 an entire MSNBC panel
mocks the Romney family for having a
black grandchild Melissa harris-perry
was actually forced to apologise on air
for it but this is how many on the left
field Republicans aren't allowed to have
cross racial relatives or friends
because they're obviously terrible
racists or perhaps they're not the
terrible racist maybe the actual
terrible racists are the people who
think that anyone who disagrees with
them has to be incapable of racial
acceptance the people who connect race
and politics inextricably people who
make jokes about Asian dolls from Toys R
Us for example I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the bench
yo show
alrighty so here we are it's a brand new
day and lots to talk about first in
breaking news apparently the trump
administration is not going to be
putting the the US Embassy in Israel in
Jerusalem there they're going to be
leaving it in Tel Aviv that's not a
tremendous shock except for the fact
that they had been promised a bunch of
times but not a huge surprise we'll talk
about that a little bit more tomorrow in
detail but the big story of the day is
obviously the jeff Sessions hearing the
Attorney General of the United States
Trump's appointment to the attorney
generalship he's being ripped apart by
the left we will get to all of that in
just one second as well as the innate
leftism the innate racism of the left in
one second but first we have to say
hello to our advertisers at bull and
branch and thank you to them obviously
for helping a sponsor the program Boland
branch fantastic company I've now
ordered three pairs of sheets from
bowlin branch because they are so good
these are the most comfortable sheets
I've ever slept on they are first-rate
I'm somebody doesn't sleep well normally
I sleep very lightly and sheet quality I
never knew until you have great sheets
you actually don't know what you're
missing you don't know what it's like to
sleep on a good sheet until you've
actually slept on the good sheet and so
I've been sleeping on you know tarps
that I get from the local gas station
but then I got ball and branch and I got
to say that the quality of the sheets is
fantastic I sleep better they breathe
they're very comfortable and they make
everything from betting two blankets
it's made from pure one hundred percent
organic cotton which means they start
out super soft and then they get
actually softer over time I can attest I
love them apparently three ex-presidents
sleep on bull and branch sheets which
means that a lot of other people who are
not married to this president's if
you're Bill Clinton presumably also have
slept and enjoyed bull and bran sheets
but the sheets themselves are fantastic
right now you go there and you get fifty
dollars off your first order from bowl
and branch fifty bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch calm
promo code been luxury sheets like
really really nice sheets can cost like
a thousand dollars bowl and bran sheets
run a couple hundred bucks it sounds
expensive until you realize that you
sleep on those sheets like all the time
right every night you can wash them once
a week and that's it you the same parish
it's fantastic so fifty percent fifty
dollars off your first set of sheets
from Boland branch at bull and britta
bull and branch calm promo code been
bull and branch calm promo club and I
really cannot recommend this product
highly enough I okay I really do love my
bowl and branch sheets
and as I say I have gone out and bought
three pairs of them myself because I
like them so much so beyond the
advertiser discount that I get I
actually went out and bought the product
cuz it's that good okay so lots to get
to we begin today with the with the
hubbub over Jeff session so the senator
from Alabama who I know a little bit
personally he's always been very cordial
to me very nice guy he's also been
slammed as a racist by people on the
left without real evidence so here is
what they say to call him a racist and
we can just implode these myths right
now apparently there was a back in the
1980s the Democrats smeared him with
accusations of racism which included
calling a black attorney boy equipping
about the KKK joking that a white
attorney was a traitor to his race
because he was collaborating with civil
rights group calling the n-double-a-cp
and ACLU on American and prosecuting a
civil rights organization for voter
fraud except that pretty much all of
those remarks were made in front of a
black lawyer and even the lawyer who
accused sessions of racism acknowledged
that sessions was clearly joking so you
just didn't like the jokes and then he
accused sessions of being a real-life
racist well honest-to-goodness if every
joke didn't anybody ever made that has a
racial undertone were taken seriously
then I'm pretty certain that almost one
hundred percent of the population would
be labeled a racist in these sorts of
hearings and that's what Democrats do
they like to they can't find any
evidence in in sessions record of actual
racism instead what they seek to do is
dredge up old conversations in which he
told the joke that somebody didn't like
that must mean that he's a racist that's
really gross the weekly Standard's mark
Hemingway is written about this he says
the US Attorney sessions filed several
cases to desegregate schools in Alabama
he prosecuted the head of the state clin
Henry Francis haze from ducting and
killing Michael Donald a black teenager
selected at random he insisted on the
death penalty when he was elected the
State Attorney General Sessions followed
through he made sure Hayes was executed
the successful prosecution of Hayes led
to a 7 million dollar civil judgment
against the Klan which effectively
destroyed the KKK in Alabama the left
doesn't like sessions because sessions
is a very hardcore law and order guy
he's not going to be cracking down on
police for stupid reasons like the the
holder Justice Department in the Lynch
Justice Department have done he's very
strong any legal immigration he was
asked at the hearings this morning about
the deferred action for childhood
arrivals program under Barack Obama he
said look we're going to enforce the law
it's Congress has drawn a job to make
the law it's my job to enforce
this is exactly right this is how
government is supposed to work the
executive branch is the executive branch
they execute it is not their job to
individually rewrite law I'm good for
sessions well the left must declare him
a liar that's that's what they have to
do they have to declare him a liar and
racist and so they are now trotting out
all sorts of people saying this the
Democratic Party has released a video
about Jeff Sessions suggesting that he
is of course a racist when Donald Trump
needed to find an attorney general all
he had to do was look to his alt right
Republican Senator Jeff Sessions was a
US attorney in Alabama when then
President Ronald Reagan nominated him
for the federal court but the
appointment broke down at sessions 1986
confirmation hearing when allegations
over his alleged racial remarks took
center stage jeff Sessions is a man
ahead of his time he was alt right when
it was still just called racism Thomas
figures a black former assistant US
attorney in Alabama testified sessions
called him boy joked about the Ku Klux
Klan and warned him about the way he
spoke to white people that was then but
who is jeff Sessions now session is
still a racist Jeff session has shown
both in his career as a US Attorney but
also in his career as a united states
senator has been a hostility to the
enforcement of civil rights particularly
in the area of voting rights he's also
opposed to same-sex marriage roe v wade
equal pay the Violence Against Women Act
and universal background checks for gun
purchases so they're saying that he's
against same-sex marriage and it doesn't
make you a bad nominee for attorney
general lots of people are roe v wade is
the worst legal decision in American
history outside of Dred Scott equal pay
he's not against equal pay he's against
the the federal government making it
easy to to sue people based on no
evidence of wage discrimination the
Violence Against Women Act he's not
against the against against prosecuting
violence against women the Violence
Against Women Act contains some
provisions that were not good in Rama in
actual application universal background
checks on guns he's opposed because
they're useless and stupid so the idea
here is they don't like his agenda there
for jeff Sessions must be a racist and
this is how the left always act and then
they wonder why this
this car just doesn't have any weight
anymore there are actual racists in the
United States there are actually all
right people not all people who call
themselves alt writer actually all right
there are actual Richard Spencer Jared
Taylor type all right people who are
actual out that honest-to-goodness
racists when you lump in jeff sessions
with those people all you're doing is
making those people appear legitimate
not making sessions appear illegitimate
and that's really stupid to the left but
they can't help themselves they've gone
off the rails they've been off the rails
for a long time it's just that Trump i
think has sent them finally over that
last cliff so all the protesters showed
up at this at the sessions hearing again
if these people think that this is going
to stop sessions or do anything except
make americans think that radical
leftists are out of their damn minds
they have to they have to be joking here
here's code pink at the at the event
this is what they were doing why am i
being taken out of here this man is evil
you're evil do not vote for gym sessions
yes we should take you say his name is
Jess here the crazy Code Pink
Ladies this is saying he's evil don't
vote for Bob o sessions don't vote for
Demetrius sessions he gave me gang get
his name right I'm not going to take you
very seriously on whether you think that
he's a real threat to the Republic I
don't remember being back in nineteen
thirty nine people going I can't believe
that we're going to have to fight this
evil evil dictator Hans Hitler if you
had said that then people might have
said well his name's a I'm not going to
no no he was she wasn't the only one a
bunch of people dressed up in KKK
outfits showed up as well it was
definitely look like
with day jobs people wonder what
leftists disco protest is because a lot
of them don't have jobs also if you're
if you're gonna really go through the
effort of dressing up as a KKK member
and shouting go jaffi go when you
actually get something that looks a
little more like a KKK outfit not like
you just went in the bathroom ripped off
a couple of pieces of paper towel and
wrap them around your head that's pretty
weak to you right there I mean like like
really go full out if you really going
to protest in this fashion let me just
suggest that you really you know go out
for the for the costumes ain't that hard
and goodness gracious so these people
show up and they make asses of
themselves and this is supposed to
convince Americans that sessions is a
racist or does it just convince you that
people on the Left have lost their damn
minds I'm going to go with the latter
meanwhile sessions came out and he he
immediately gives a statement he says of
course I implore the clan this you know
should go without saying but here is
Senator sessions on this let me address
another issue straight on I was accused
in 1986 I'm failing to protect the
voting rights of african-americans by
presenting the Perry County case the
voter fraud case and of condemning civil
rights advocates and organizations and
even harboring amazingly sympathies for
the KKK these addenda Blee false charges
Bob poor the Klan and what it represents
and it's hateful ideology insisted on
marsh deeds of the Southern Poverty Law
Center his lawsuit that led to the
successful collapse of the clan at least
in Alabama the seizure of their building
at least for that period of time as
Civil Rights Division attorneys have
testified before the committee I
supported fully their historic chases
that the Justice Department filed to
advance civil rights and that I
supported including cases to desegregate
schools abolish at-large elections for
cities county commissions and school
boards these at-large elections were
mechanism used to block african-american
candidates from being able to be elected
to boards and commissions he was a
deliberate and part of a systemic plan
to
reduce the ability of african-americans
to have influence in the election and
governing process okay so look sessions
knows how to defend himself he's going
to do fine he's going to sail through
confirmation but that's not going to
stop the left from trying to Hillary all
Republicans as racist horrible people
again the left can't just stick to
charges that actually work instead they
have to go to their ultimate extreme
which is calling people racist cory
booker is the senator from from New
Jersey he obviously wants to run for
president 2020 and he apparently is
going to testify against sessions today
and everybody is very much expecting him
to go out there and basically call
sessions a racist which is not only a
breach of Senate decorum it's also not
true but let's just recall a cory booker
from 2013 talking about how wondrous it
is it actually is earlier this year I
guess who's februari 2016 talking about
how wondrous it was to work with jeff
Sessions on honoring civil rights heroes
and so this is truly one of my life's
greatest moments I am humbled to be able
to participate here in paying tribute to
some of the extraordinary Americans
whose footsteps pave the way for me and
my generation I feel blessed and honored
to have partnered with Senator sessions
in being the Senate sponsors of this
important award this was just right now
now he's racist now he's going to come
out he's gonna say sessions as racist
this is the only card the Democrats have
and it doesn't work and what's even more
amusing is that the real racists here
are the Democrats because all they see
is race all they see is race and it's
it's amusing to watch them just tear
themselves apart they're so blind to
their own racism they can't even see it
so for example Hillary Clinton it was
just released who Hillary Clinton would
have appointed to her cabinet she does
not get that opportunity thank God and
what's hilarious about this list is that
she has a list of people the ghost
cabinet right and people like John
Podesta for Secretary of State just
awful right treasury secretary sheryl
sandberg defense secretary michelle
flurry keeping on Loretta Lynch's
attorney general but the one that sticks
out is environmental protection agency
is it quote okay environmental
protection agency quote likely an
african-american and or an education so
you name all these people and then you
say also the black person be named later
there's like a base
small trade where you trade a star and
you get back a bunch of minor leaguers
and it says plus a player to be named
later so you've got a bunch of cabinet
members plus a black person to be named
later according to Hillary Clinton which
again is just an incredible thing and
that is obvious racism it doesn't matter
who the black person is just matters
that it's a black person we must have a
black person at the EPA but they don't
even see their own racism this is the
lady who during the campaign lectured
Americans about their own unconscious
bias she said we all have to be worried
about our implicit bias and I as
president will go forth and explain to
white Americans all of the unconscious
bias that they Harbor inside those puny
little racist minds and here's Hillary
with our ghost cabinet and the phantom
black person right random black person
to be named later I'm not arise us and
it's just amazing my favorite story of
the day actually is this story from the
New York Times courtesy of a woman named
Farah Stockman I believe it's a female
reporter and and here is the piece it's
just fantastic I have to read it at
least a large chunk of it women's march
on Washington opens contentious
dialogues about race quote many
thousands of women are expected to
converge on the nation's capital for the
women's march on Washington the day
after John Donald J Trump's inauguration
Jennifer Willis no longer plans to be
one of them miss Willis a 50-year old
wedding minister from South Carolina had
looked forward to taking her daughters
to the March then she read a post on the
facebook page for the March they made
her feel unwelcome because she is white
the post written by a black activist
from Brooklyn who is a March volunteer
advised quote white allies to listen
more and talk less it also chided those
who had said we're only now waking up to
racism because of the election you don't
just get to join because now you're
scared to read the post I was boring
scared stung by the Tony miss Willis
canceled her trip this is a woman's
marsh she said we're supposed to be
allies in equal pay marriage adoption
why is it know about white women don't
understand black women and then the
article goes on about all of the
conflict inside this group and it's
pretty may I love this line a debate
ensued about whether white women were
just now experiencing what minority
women experience daily or having a hard
time yield in control a young white
woman from Baltimore wrote with
bitterness that white women who have
been victims of rape and abuse were
being quote asked to check their
privilege a catch phrase that refers to
people acknowledging
their advantages but which even some
liberal women find unduly
confrontational no one involves the
march fears the rancor will dampen
turnout even many of those who expressed
dismay at the tone of the discussion
said they still intended to join what is
sure to be the largest demonstration yet
against the trump presidency but the
debates over race reflect deeper
questions about the future of
progressivism in the age of Trump should
the march highlight what divides women
or what unites them is there room for
women who have never heard of white
privilege and at a time when a
presidential candidate ran against
political correctness and one with half
of white female voters supporting him is
this the time to tone down talk about
race or to double down it's it's it's
amazing i love it the left is just
ripping itself apart they're ripping
themselves apart because for the left
it's all about hierarchies of group
victimhood right so the left has this
March and supposed to be women and women
are the big victims right this is the
women's victim March we're all victims
because we have a joonas right that
means that we got to go and we got to
march together because we have uteri
accept that some there's other victim
groups that actually outrank women on
the on the wondrous scale of victimhood
in the hierarchy of victimhood gays
outrank women blacks outrank women
Hispanics out hang out ranked women and
so you can have what feminist like to
call intersectionality intersectionality
and that means that if you are a member
of one of these other hierarchical
groups and it's a higher group than the
women group then that means that we
treat you as a member of that higher
group and if you're not then we treat
you as a member of a lower group so the
white women are now victimizers they
can't be the people who lead this thing
because they don't have highest status
somewhere there is the unicorn of
intersectionality and the unicorn of
intersectionality is a is a pansexual
transgender black Hispanic Native
American woman right that's it if you
get all those then you're the unicorn of
intersectionality and you have ultimate
moral authority to say everything and no
one can ever say anything to you or
about you no one can ever say anything
that differs from you we all just have
to anoint you dictator under
intersectionality and then you get to be
the person in charge of the rest of the
world because you are the ultimate
victim you that you have fallen prey to
every form of victimhood there ever was
and everyone else must bow down before
your cherished victimhood status and the
left is tearing itself apart over this
and it's delicious because no one in the
real world cares about this stuff no one
in the real world cares whether you're a
woman or the
whether they're Hispanic there are
racist there are sexist but that's not
the way America works folks okay most
Americans don't care enough about you to
be racist or sexist most Americans are
not sitting around going how do we stop
these particular women we must stop that
black woman because she's black most
people don't have time for that people
have jobs people have families and
mostly people just are apathetic about
other people like the great lie about
society is that we all care deeply about
one another it's not really true you
care deeply about your family you care
deeply about your friends and the person
who lives a hundred miles away from you
yeah you care somewhat about them but
when you read their flood washed away
the guys home did you really run your
wallet not really that's human nature
okay it's just how it works now the bad
side means you didn't rush to your
wallet when the guys home washed away
the good news means you're not going to
go burn down that guy's home because you
don't know I mean don't care about it
and so the fact is that according to the
left is the sort of group identity stuff
is what politics is supposed to be all
about and so they've tried to voice that
on the right you're racist or sexist
your bigots but there are the ones who
are exercising members of their own
groups are you can be a member of their
group but if you don't hit that
cherished high status if you're not the
unicorn then you may actually be
targeted we have to stop for a second
and say thank you to another one of our
advertisers legacy box if you haven't
checked out legacy box i highly
recommend it i'm somebody who truly
believes i really do that it's important
to preserve the memories of your
childhood preserve memories from your
parents i used to run the company in
which I actually helped people write
their memoirs because I think it's that
important to preserve memory because
it's the only record a lot of us have of
people who have passed on or just people
who you are just memories that you want
to keep legacy box helps you do that in
a unique and wonderful way what they do
is they send you a box to your house and
you send back all your old tapes in your
film and your pictures and your audio
recordings and you load up that box and
they send them back to you in a couple
of weeks on a thumb drive around a DVD
so you preserve all your memories you
don't have to worry about the moths
getting to it you don't have to worry
about the the film's of grading it's
ready to watch and share and relive and
enjoy fantastic father's day mother's
day gift fantastic Valentine's Day gift
it's a really really good product legacy
box my parents have used it actually 25
well 250,000 families across the country
have used it my parents are ecstatic
about my dad dug out the the tapes of
his father and he's now sent those to
legacy boxes looking
order receiving back the DVD right now
if you go to legacy box.com / ben you
get a forty percent discount on your
orders that's pretty heavy / on the
price and and that's a that's a pretty
great price to begin with so legacy box
calm / Ben get that forty percent
discount and they guarantee that all of
your stuff comes back to you you get to
you get to slap a little label on it to
make sure that they can track it through
the process tell you where it is
terrific terrific stuff legacy box calm
/ pens get that forty percent discount
on your legacy box okay so also the
Democratic Party is falling apart
because they're tearing each other apart
they're tearing themselves apart they're
more interested in the in the genius of
intersectionality than they are in
building an actual coalition which is
why they're falling apart and losing
white voters I promise you this lady
this Willis woman who was going to go
and March with this woman's Martian
isn't going to anymore next time around
if she doesn't vote Republican her kids
will think about it because at a certain
point they're going to realize I don't
want to be seen it's funny they say we
all just want to be seen as women why
don't you want to be seen as a human why
don't you just get rid of all the
categories you want to be seen as an
individual human being with qualities
and attributes and eventually when
people get tired of being portrayed as
just a member of a group no more than
your group you want to be seen as an
individual and that's when you become
prey to me right that's when you become
prey to conservatism and conservative
ideology which is all about judging
people as individuals based on their
actions not based on their intentions
and not based on their group identity
okay we have to break here on facebook
for and watch the rest of the show we
have a lot coming up go to daily
wire.com and become a subscriber eight
bucks a month will buy you a
subscription to daily wire calm we have
a bunch of new goodies coming out in the
next six weeks or so you can get I think
right now if you get an annual
subscription you still get a free copy
of free signed copy of my book true
allegiance my novel true allegiance and
that has been flying off the shelf so go
to daily wire.com for that also you get
the rest of the show on video if you're
if you're listening right now you get to
watch me on video that shows much better
on video than it is even even orally
which is saying a lot since it's a
fantastic show even if you're just
listening to it but if you if you're
watching it it's even better you got
Andrew Klavan shake it to be part of the
mailbag which we do in a couple of days
I think in the near future we're going
to add a friday show we're gonna add
some extra goodies behind the scenes for
for daily wire
calm so make sure that you go to to
daily wire calm right now get that
subscription and join us on the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you